je sais à quel point c'est dur de ne
plus voir ses parents tu sais si je suis
passionné de légende c'est parce que je
suis moi aussi à la recherche de ma mère
disparue c'est vrai oui c'est mon voeu
le plus précieux de réussir à retrouver
un jour et je sais maintenant que ce
jour approche je sais comme on l'a
retrouvé grâce à cette légende de trolls
qui dit qu'une ans atteints tu veux dire
que en sommes pas raconter celle là
aussi non regarde ça on l'appelle la
pierre aux souhaits si une personne la
trouve effet un voeu il se réalisera
ça fait longtemps maintenant que je
cherche cette pierre les trolls n'ont
pas pu m'aider ils ne savent pas où
elles se cachent les grottes du sultanat
doman que la gao le temple les trolls
connaissent parfaitement cet endroit tu
sais mais personne ne peut y aller c'est
interdit un quart des oui c'est très
dangereux on risque d'être maudit ou de
se faire jeter un sort où on peut causer
des problèmes à toute la ville et même
au monde entier allons-y où ça allons
trouver cette pierre reçoit tu n'es pas
le seul à avoir un voeu à faire mais tu
oublies qu'on n'a pas le droit d'y aller
pour le mouillé je ferais n'importe quoi
pour ma mère